[Musique]
on se trouve à la ferme refuge des
croquettes épines et ici c'est toute la
partie refuge avec tous les animaux qui
sont en repos que ce soit les books
castrés ou alors les vieilles chèvres
qui sont à la retraite et qui profitent
du soleil du matin
une ferme annule l'autre pareil depuis
12 ans Alexandra élève son troupeau en
dehors du mode d'exploitation
traditionnelle ici une quarantaine de
chefs produit le lait quand les autres
plus de 150 se reposent le principe de
la retraite par répartition adapté au
monde caprin ici on est dans la partie
chèvrerie avec les laitières donc c'est
elle qui produisent le lait qui me
permet de fabriquer le fromage et qui
est vendu en vente directe en bio donc
avec un maximum de plus-value pour
pouvoir nourrir à la fois les laitières
et une grosse partie des besoins du
refuge que ce soit l'alimentation ou les
frais vétérinaires
chaque chèvre et Chérie avec une
attention singulière tout est mis en
oeuvre pour le bien-être de cet animal
particulièrement espiègle et affectueux
j'attends deux à trois ans que les
chèvres est quasiment fini leur
croissance avant qu'elle mette bas et
ensuite une fois qu'elles ont eu leur
premier petit et que la lactation est
lancée j'entretiens la lactation au
maximum que ce soit une adaptation
longue sur plusieurs années pour pour
éviter justement le stress et la fatigue
des mises bas c'est surtout ça pour les
chèvres qui est le plus le plus
difficile
cela évite également certains problèmes
sanitaires parvenus à l'âge de 8-10 ans
aucune n'est envoyé à l'abattoir comme
dans un élevage conventionnel mais
intègre le refuge et profite d'une
retraite méritée
et t'occuper de l'eau situé au confins
des trois provinces Touraine Sologne
Berry la ferme produit 300 de fromages
vendu sur place sur les marchés et même
à Paris je suis en train de démouler les
bûches donc moi comme je suis juste en
bio et que je rentre dans aucun cahier
des charges je j'ai des bûches j'ai des
pyramides et j'ai ce que j'appelle des
grands cabris parce que je peux pas leur
donner le nom de la op on AOP c'est du
Sainte-Maure-de-Touraine du Valençay et
du sel sur Cher
naturellement ce modèle économique n'est
pas viable financièrement mais cette
ancienne ingénieur agronome qui a
parcouru le monde assume ses choix et
convictions c'est vrai que c'est dur
mais il y a pas cette notion de
sacrifice ou de croix je préfère être en
accord avec moi-même même si ça coûte
cher effectivement de garder des animaux
non productifs mais il y a une ambiance
au niveau du troupeau il y a une
ambiance au niveau de la ferme il y a
une qualité de de vie et de travail ça a
pas de prix
une cagnotte litchi a été lancée
dernièrement objectif recueillir 19000
euros pour aménager une infirmerie les
dons sont possibles jusqu'à fin avril ou
ensuite directement à l'association rock
épine